- Welcome to ARC312,
where we're gonna talk
about how AWS builds regions
and hopefully what that means for you.
My name's Don McGarry.
I'm a principal engineer in EC2.
- And my name is Michelle Thissen.
I'm a principal TPM, also with EC2.
So before we kick it off,
let's do a quick overview
on what we're actually gonna
be talking about today.
So we'll start with a very quick recap
on AWS Global Infrastructure concepts.
We'll talk about how
we build for resiliency
and how you can do the same.
We'll take you on a journey back in time
on how we used to do
builds and then transition
to how we do things today,
because things have changed
a lot in the past decade.
We'll then talk about
availability zones and local zones
and then talk in a lot
more detail on dependencies
since those are the primary
problem when it comes to builds.
And then we'll leave you
with some key takeaways.
So first, let's talk about
our AWS global infrastructure.
So this map, you'll see all
of the AWS regions we have.
The ones in green are the ones
that have already been launched,
and the ones in red are the
ones we're currently working on.
And those include the EU Sovereign Cloud,
Chile, and the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia.
So overall, right now, we have 38 regions,
and we're continuing to
add to those as we go,
including more availability zones
and other expansion
options like local zones.
So this is our local zone map.
We have 38 metro areas at the moment,
and we're expanding heavily
in that space as well
because there's a lot of customer interest
in leveraging local zones,
but we'll dive more into that later.
So next up, let's dive a little bit deeper
on how you can think about
our global infrastructure.
- So the highest level of abstraction
in AWS's global
infrastructure is a partition.
Most customers don't necessarily
need to think in terms
of partitions because
most customers are working
in what we would call
the commercial partition.
If you look at an ARN, it says arn::aws,
that's the partition, so
the commercial partition
is the AWS partition.
That's where most customers live.
But we've had multiple
partitions for quite some time.
There's the US GovCloud
partition, which is us-gov.
There's the China partition, aws-cn.
And the reason we wanted
to kinda call this out
in this talk is the
upcoming EU Sovereign Cloud
is going to launch, and that
will be its own partition.
So, a lot more customers
will be having to deal
with the partition
abstraction than before.
The difference with, you know,
between partitions is
partitions have an instance
of our global services in them.
So, most notably,
IAM and Route 53 are the two
global services that will,
you know, come to mind when you need
to work across multiple partitions.
And what does that mean
is an IAM identity,
which includes an account number,
in the commercial partition,
there's no concept of that
identity in another partition
because they're two separate stacks.
So, you know, if you need to migrate
an application across or
build it in a new partition,
things like IAM principles
and account numbers
will be different because those
are two different software stacks.
So, you know, outside
of the global services,
partitions are just grouped
for one or more regions
that can be contained within
one and only one partition.
Now we'll dig into a little
bit more in terms of regions,
availability zones, and local zones.
So, and our region is
just a geographic area
where we offer our services.
Regions are comprised of three
or more availability zones.
And as a customer, you
can just kinda think
of an availability zone as a data center.
In reality, there can be tens to even,
in some cases, hundreds of data centers
that make up an individual
availability zone.
Those data centers
within availability zone
are very close to each other
from a latency perspective,
both from a network path and
from a shared fate perspective.
So each availability
zone within that zone,
you can kinda think of it as sharing fate
from an availability perspective.
But when we pick where we
want our availability zones
to be in a region, we want
them to be close enough
to each other to maintain
single-digit millisecond latency
between those availability zones,
but they're far enough away
that they won't share fate
with each other from things
like natural disasters,
power events.
So, our regions are architected
such that if you spread
your workload across
multiple availability zones,
it's unlikely to have shared fate
in an outage across
those availability zones.
And we extend that into
our software stack as well,
which we'll talk a little bit more about.
We kind of extended the
idea of an availability zone
to this thing called a local zone.
And a local zone, you can
think of it as an extension
of an availability zone.
So a local zone is parented to
a single AZ within a region,
but that local zone can be,
from a latency perspective,
a pretty far distance away.
And that what that does is
the control plane that will,
you know, launch instances
in that local zone exists
in the parent availability
zone, but the capacity
that's running your
workload is in a metro area
closer to your customers or, in some cases
for like machine learning, in an area
where we're able to
acquire lots more power
to be able to run machine learning,
either inference or training workloads.
So, we've used the
availability zone concept
to essentially stretch capacity in an AZ
to either bring it closer
to your customer's workloads
or to provide additional capacity
for things like machine learning.
Michelle will dig a little bit more into,
like how these concepts
apply when you're thinking
about them in your architecture.
- So let's talk a bit about how
we can build for resiliency.
So we've talked about
regions, availability zones,
so let's put this into an example here.
So we have a region.
We've selected two availability zones,
and our VPC spans those
two availability zones.
And what we wanna explain here
is that understanding
the scope of the services
that you're using is really important.
So in this architecture diagram,
we have our load balancer
and auto scaling group
and our EC2 instances.
But what you'll see is
that our EC2 instances
are in specific availability zones.
And that's because when
you launch an EC2 instance,
you specify the AZ.
And so this is a zonal service.
As opposed to these services such as S3,
CloudWatch, DynamoDB,
these are regional services.
So they exist at the regional level.
When you create an S3 bucket
and put objects into that bucket,
you do it at the region level.
You don't specify an AZ.
And the reason why
understanding this is important
is because you can plan
your operational responses accordingly.
You can look at what metrics
are important to your business
and then make business
decisions based off of that.
For example, knowing when to
scale up your EC2 instances
or when you need to fail over in the event
of a disaster recovery scenario.
For the majority of our
customers, you know,
leveraging multiple availability
zones within a region
is sufficient as Don mentioned.
However, there are specific use cases
where a multi-region
strategy might make sense.
But that does come with
some additional complexities
managing DNS and costs
if you're replicating
your entire environment
in a different region.
So, hopefully, this is a good introduction
into some global infrastructure concepts,
kind of framing it with
resiliency in mind.
Let's actually jump into
how we build new regions.
So, region builds have changed
a ton over the last decade.
Even in the last few years,
things have changed significantly.
However, there are two
primary work streams
that have remained fairly consistent.
The first is the physical.
So, I know we talk about
the elusive AWS cloud.
At the end of the day,
there's still servers in data centers.
And so the physical work
stream consists of everything
from picking proposed sites,
including looking at expansion options.
When we first build a region, you know,
we have three availability zones,
but in the future, we might want to add
additional availability zones.
So we have to keep that
in mind when planning
and picking our locations
because as Don mentioned,
we have requirements on how far apart
the data centers can be.
So, we need to consider all of
that when picking the sites.
Sorry.
And then we have to
construct the data centers,
delivering cable, all of the racks,
and then connect everything
to the AWS network.
The second work stream is, of course,
the software build, and we're
gonna spend most of our time
in this work stream.
And this involves
everything from building out
the most foundational
things such as, you know,
making sure that services
can authenticate,
all the way out to building
all of the AWS services
in the new region.
So as I mentioned, we've always
had these two work streams,
but the way we go about builds
has actually changed a lot.
So, let's take it back to 2010
when we were building the
first region in South America.
- Yeah, so in 2010,
AWS launch, announced the
launch of the Sao Paulo Region.
It was our eighth region.
We were the first major cloud
provider to launch a region
on the South American continent.
And AWS looked a lot different back then.
And the way that, you know,
you can see from the blog
post with the old logo.
The way that we built regions
was pretty different back then,
and to talk about how we built Brazil,
we'll have to meet you,
introduce you to John,
our fictional character.
John, which John was an actual person.
That's not John.
They don't let us put, you know,
real people in the slides.
John, his job title was
region bootstrap ninja.
And John would be at
the office in Seattle,
and you know, it'd be like,
hey, it's time to go build Sao Paulo.
We've built the data centers.
The racks arrived.
John, here's three jump drives,
one for each availability zone.
And John would get on a plane,
go up to the availability
zone, kinda walk in there.
Whatever server kinda, you know,
struck his fancy, he'd
plug in that jump drive
and literally start hand-hacking away,
installing all of the bootstrap scripts
to be able to launch, at the time,
our internal virtualization infrastructure
that predated EC2.
And this worked good for a while.
The problem with this is, you know,
over time, John needed to learn
a lotta stuff, right?
So, you know, it was like
provisioning network equipment
and then, you know, provisioning,
you know, our Zen stack
and then like having to do
a whole bunch of like Red
Hat things and, you know,
so John needed to learn
more and more and more,
so it was kinda hard to
train more Johns over time.
The second thing that got
pretty challenging was,
you know, for all of us
technically inclined here,
you know, if I sit down at a
computer and you ask me to do
a step of about 30 or so different things,
I'll usually do about
28 of 'em really good
the first time and then, you know,
I'll fat-finger one or two things,
and then it won't work,
and I'll have to go back
and debug it and then, you know,
by this time, I'm on the
second and the third AZ.
I'm getting kinda lazy, so
I'm making more mistakes.
So like, you know,
sending one person there
to do lots of stuff is a
pretty error-prone process.
And flying people around the world
that are a limited
resource isn't a good way
to be able to scale to
multiple region builds at once.
So, you know,
we managed to build eight
regions this way, which is,
you know, I think pretty good.
But there were some other
changes happening on,
you know, kinda behind the scenes that,
you know, unfortunately,
you know, put John's ninja
bootstrap role kind of on ice.
And the first thing
was we've kind of continually
innovated over time.
So I mentioned that
when AWS first launched,
we ran the original
services like S3 and SQS,
and some of those early services
ran on the infrastructure
that this website, amazon.com,
you may have heard of it, ran on.
And then we launched EC2, and,
you know, we thought that was really cool.
I think it's the best service.
And over time, we started to build
all of our AWS services on top of EC2.
In fact, today, when you
launch an instance in EC2,
the machine that talks to the server
that launches your instance for you,
that is actually an EC2 instance.
So EC2 runs on top of EC2.
So everything runs on EC2
now, which kinda makes the,
you know, John walks into a data center
and goes to plug and jump
drives and run servers.
That doesn't really work
because you need EC2
to be able to run EC2 and, you know,
your head starts to hurt.
The other thing is we came up with things
like IAM opt-in regions where
when we launch a new region,
your IAM information for
your account doesn't exist
in that region yet until you as a customer
opt into using that region,
and then your IAM materials
will propagate to a regional
propagator in that region.
Again, that made it really,
really challenging for,
you know, oh, I walk into the data center
and I start installing stuff 'cause like,
we need this regional
identity stack to exist.
So, like, we kept innovating over time.
Customers wanted things
like digital sovereignty
and data protection and, you know,
more regions to be able
to run their workload
closer to their customers.
And so the demand for us to
grow our global footprint
continue to increase over time.
And that kinda gets to one
of like the fundamental value
props that we talked about
about cloud from the
first re:Invent actually,
is the ability to go
global in minutes, right?
I can be sitting in my
house in Northern Virginia
and launch an instance in Australia
just from the management console, right?
I don't have to travel there
and figure out colo space
and do all this other stuff.
And you know, in order to make good
on that value proposition to customers,
we needed to expand our global footprint
pretty aggressively.
So, you know, the global reach
of what our customers wanted
to run on our platform
really, really pushed us
to expand further and further.
So with all this, how the heck
did we build regions today?
- Well, it's now 2025.
Can't believe I'm saying that.
That's wild. And what have we done?
Well, we have continued
to launch more regions
and availability zones and local zones.
I just included these blog posts
from some of the more recent
regions that we've launched.
But this just wouldn't have been possible
using the approach that
we used a while ago.
So, let's dive into how
we build regions today.
So, as Don mentioned, you know,
it was a very sequential process.
We would do the physical
build and then fly people in
and do the software build.
And in order to scale, we
had to parallelize this work.
So, how do we do that?
Well, we just build AWS on AWS.
So we have all of these existing
regions around the world.
So what we do now is we
use those existing regions
to bootstrap the new regions.
So instead of waiting around
until the physical work
stream is complete,
we get a headstart with a software build.
And so we can parallelize the effort.
So, we have a build region here.
It's still under construction.
We're still super early
on in the planning phase.
No racks have landed,
but we're gonna get a
headstart on this region build.
So, we're gonna select
an existing AWS region.
We'll refer to this as
our bootstrap region.
Now, we're very careful when
selecting our bootstrap region
because it's, you know,
a production region.
We have customers running there.
So we look into things like
capacity considerations,
the network latency between
the bootstrap region
and the build region, because
at the end of the day,
you know, we need traffic
to go back and forth,
and we don't wanna be traveling
all the way around the
world every single time.
And then fiber considerations.
And so once we've selected
this bootstrap region,
we go ahead and start that software build.
So even super, super, super
early on in this build,
we're designing with resiliency in mind.
So our bootstrap VPC
here is already spanning
three availability zones.
And everything that we build
in this bootstrap environment,
every service, everything thinks it exists
in the new build region.
And we connect it up, and eventually,
we will, you know, get the racks landed
and everything good to go.
But let's dive a little bit deeper
into what's happening
in that bootstrap VPC.
- Yeah, so we start with a VPC,
and we have an account just
like any other customer.
Well, we need to make this VPC
look like the region that we're building.
So, we need to start
building some services.
Well, that's pretty easy.
I can launch an instance,
and I can give it to a
service team and say,
"Hey, here you go.
It's all good."
Well, the service team's gonna go,
"Hey, this is great,
except I need to get,
I need to get my AWS software on there.
How am I gonna do that?"
Ooh, that's a problem.
Well,
so, the Amazon deployment system
can't tell this AWS account
from any of the other
millions of AWS accounts.
So we need a way to
authenticate that host,
and then we need a way to
talk to our deployment system,
and then we need a way
to make it look like it's the
build region inside there.
Well, but, okay,
so we need to install
some software on that.
That's just like an RPM, right?
And what's really an RPM repo?
It's just a web server.
And we're gonna need
to do some DNS trickery
because we're gonna need to
make DNS inside this environment
look like the region or the
zone that we're building in.
But what really is DNS?
It's just something that
answers on UDP 53 based on,
you know, something I
look up in a database.
I can surely fake that out.
And then most of our host identification,
well, that's just a certificate.
Well, I can issue certificates.
So, what we did in order to
kinda fake all this stuff
until the real services that
do all these things come up
is we launched another instance,
and we called it the Franken instance
'cause it just kinda pieces
together all of this stuff
that you need to break
the circular dependencies
to get that host to talk
to the deployment system
to be able to get software on it.
So we made a Franken
instance, and it does DNS,
and it does PKI, and it
does a little RPM repo,
and that'll turn that generic EC2 instance
into an Amazon service team host.
And we can do that to build
the early services like IAM,
'cause that's what you need
before you need anything else, right?
You know, who am I talking to,
and how do I authorize them?
All right, cool.
So we built IAM, right?
So this should be easy.
Now we just gotta build EC2.
So, in order to build EC2, I've got IAM.
Great.
Well, remember when I mentioned that,
like, everything runs on top of EC2?
EC2 also uses some other
AWS services because,
you know, we didn't wanna
be left out of the fun.
So we use most notably S3 and DynamoDB.
And in a production region,
the way that we use S3 and DynamoDB
is really strongly kind of
controlled and monitored
such that if those services impair,
like we've got a way to either continue
portions of our operations
or we'll degrade
relative to those services degrading.
But early on in the build,
we've got like a chicken
and the egg problem, right?
Because S3 needs EC2 to build,
but EC2 needs S3 to build.
So we've got a problem.
But I'm running into AWS account,
and there's S3 and Dynamo in the region.
And what's really the difference
between S3 and Dynamo
in the bootstrap region
and S3 and Dynamo in the build region?
Well, the only difference really
is the DNS is different, right?
So if I was building US East 2,
it would be s3.useast2.amazonaws.com.
And if my donor was US East 1,
the donor would be s3.useast1.amazonaws.
That's just DNS.
I can fix that 'cause I
have the Franken instance.
I can just make DNS whatever I want.
And then when I auth, I need to auth
against that regional opt-in stack,
because when you're in
a regionalized account,
you need to talk to the
regional opt-in stack.
Well, so what if I just drew a
little proxy server in there?
That responded on that DNS endpoint,
shuffled your auth over to
the auth that we just built.
But then when it actually
goes to store your data,
it just turns around and uses the one
in the bootstrap region.
That's what we do.
We have these little intelligent proxies,
which, like a good mullet,
is build region in the front,
bootstrap region in the back.
And that's how we break the
circular dependencies early on
in EC2 to be able to allow us to use S3
in order to build EC2.
And then once we build EC2,
then S3 and Dynamo can build,
and Michelle will talk
a little bit about that.
- Yep.
So, at this point, you know,
EC2's core dependencies are up,
and we can build out
the EC2 control plane.
We also build out some
core networking services
and other services in this
bootstrap environment.
And then, you know, in our build region,
we're at the point where
the racks have been cabled,
and we can actually launch EC2 instances
into the build region
using the control plane
that exists in the bootstrap VPC.
And once we can launch instances, well,
that means that other services
can start their builds.
And so the first few services
that build in the build region
are S3 and DynamoDB among
a few other core services.
Once S3 and Dynamo are
available in the build region,
we actually go ahead
and migrate things over.
So we take all of the data
stored in the bootstrap region,
S3 and DynamoDB, and
we copy that over to S3
and DynamoDB in the build region.
We also then migrate all of
the services that were built
in the bootstrap VPC
into the build region.
And the way we do this is
service teams will scale up
their instances in the build region
and then scale down those
in the bootstrap VPC.
And remember, this is all
possible because to a service,
they are the same region,
whether it's the VPC environment
or the build region environment.
And so once the control
plane is up and running
in the build region, we have EC2,
S3, DynamoDB, all of the core
services in the build region.
So we have a very stable environment
so that a bunch of other services
can start their builds as well.
Once that's done, we
go ahead and terminate
all of the resources in the
bootstrap, S3 and DynamoDB.
We also shut down and eventually terminate
all of the instances that we're running
in the bootstrap VPC.
We then apply an access
control list to block traffic
from the bootstrap region
to the build region
and vice versa.
We then give it some bake
time just to make sure
that nothing is tryna call
back and forth anymore.
If everything looks good,
we go ahead and disconnect
the build region from
the bootstrap region,
and then the build region is on its own.
We build out all of the
services, we run our game days,
and then we launch the region.
So that is at a very high level
how we build a new AWS region.
Let's now jump to how we do this
for availability zones and local zones.
- Yeah, so availability zones,
it's a very similar process,
albeit a lot simpler actually.
But what's interesting
about availability zones
is it actually takes us longer
to add a new availability
zone onto an existing region
than it does to build a
new region from scratch.
And you're probably like,
"Come on, man, why?"
- [Michelle] We're working on it, though.
- Yeah, we are working
on making it better,
but the reason is our isolation and,
you know, our promise
to customers is that,
you know, one region is strongly isolated
from another region.
So, and when we're running
in that bootstrap VPC,
we don't do anything special.
We're just like any other customer.
So we're not doing
anything that will impact
the region that we're running in.
We really are running
like a brand new region.
So that's pretty isolated
from everything else
in the global AWS infrastructure stack.
And there's no customers
in a build region yet,
so we can go really fast.
And we do.
With an availability zone,
you're operating in a live
region with live customers.
So from an availability perspective,
there are a whole bunch
of rules that we follow
about deployment safety and not deploying
to more than one zone in a region on a day
and not deploying to so many zones.
And so, like all of those rules apply,
and we wanna be really, really cautious
that we don't do something
in a build availability zone
that would impact customers
running in the parent region.
So, we are expanding our
availability zones worldwide
and that it's, in some ways, nice
because it's a way to
get additional resiliency
and additional capacity available
to customers without you
having to rebuild your
stack in a new region.
So, you know, provide some
greater flexibility there.
And the way that we do
it is we essentially,
instead of having a bootstrap region,
we have a bootstrap AZ.
And we just create a VPC
there, and it's a much smaller,
you know, that is to scale.
It's a much smaller VPC.
We only build the zonal
services that comprise
the EC2 control plane in there
as well as some of the
zonal networking services.
And then we do some fancy
under-the-hood network peering
to the zone that's being built.
And once we can do that, we can provision
hardware and launch instances
and be able to do that
same migration process
that we do in the region build process.
So somewhat similar, slightly different.
And you know, the fun fact
is it actually takes longer,
mostly due to deployment safety.
- So let's talk a bit
about local zones next.
So local zones exist so customers
can run their applications
on AWS infrastructure
closer to their end users
and to provide additional capacity.
So we have a few different
flavors of local zones.
We have our standard local zones,
and we have dedicated local zones,
which are dedicated to
a specific customer,
which means they might
come with additional,
you know, security services
or whatever that customer may require.
And similar to an availability
zone, we have a parent AZ.
And the EC2 control plane
lives in that parent AZ,
and then we just extend
over to the local zone.
So the set of services that we build
for a local zone is much, much smaller.
Most of the complexity
in a local zone build
actually comes from setting
up the network connectivity
between the parent AZ and the local zone.
But similar to the AZ, you know,
once we have that established,
we can provision that capacity,
the data plane essentially,
in the local zone.
And one of the huge benefits
here is that customers
can run their workloads in
different countries, for example.
So say you have a parent
region in country A,
but due to data residency requirements,
you need to store all of
your data in country B.
Well, using a local zone, you could use
some of the local zone
versions of regional services
like S3 Express to ensure
that all of your data
is stored in country B
to meet the data residency
requirements you may have.
So it's a really nifty way of, you know,
extending AWS infrastructure capabilities
to locations beyond where we have regions.
Next up, we're going to jump
into perhaps the most tricky
part in all of this building.
So, we're gonna talk about dependencies
and how we deal with this during builds.
So Don touched on this
a little bit earlier.
It's quite tricky because we have a lot
of circular dependencies between services,
and it continues to become
more and more complicated
as we add more services, more features,
and more services wanting
to leverage the benefits
of services that we've
developed previously.
Like think of Lambda, Fargate.
If you're a service team,
why wouldn't you wanna use those, right?
So we've kind of broken it
up into four main categories.
The first is service bring-up.
So, this is all about how we bring up
all of the AWS services during a build.
So we have, you know,
hundreds of external AWS services,
but probably thousands
of internal services.
So the way we handle
bringing those up in batches
involves quite a bit of complexity,
and we'll go through that
using an example later.
Then of dependency management.
Dependencies change all the time.
It's almost impossible to
maintain an accurate list
of dependencies, especially
at a granular level.
From a program management perspective,
when we build a new region
or availability zone
or local zone, we do have a
high-level dependency graph.
This allows us to, you know,
plan the schedule and make sure we launch
the builds on time, but it's
much higher level than at,
you know, the individual service level
because that's just almost
impossible to maintain.
Then we have static stability,
so making sure things recover gracefully
in the event that something goes wrong.
And then continuous testing.
So ensuring that all the
things that we planned for,
we actually test and
make sure that they work.
So, to frame dependencies and
how problematic they can be,
we're gonna run you through an example.
We'll use EC2's most
foundational API, run-instances,
and talk you through it.
- Yeah, so up until this point,
everything sounds pretty easy, right?
I mean, I think it's easy.
So, what does it take to run an instance?
This is a really simple
run instance call, right?
Give me an instance from NAT AMI,
make it a t3 micro, and
I'll give it a key pair.
What does that look like? Oh, wow.
So this is actually a screenshot
from our internal API
orchestration software
that we use in EC2.
That is what a run
instance call looks like.
Every one of those boxes on that chart,
be them purple or yellow,
are what we call agents.
And an agent represents a service team.
And a service team in
AWS is a two-pizza team.
So it's roughly eight to 10 engineers.
And when you work on a two-pizza team,
you are responsible for your service,
and you own everything about that service.
So in this API orchestration
framework thingy
that we have, if you hover over a box,
when you hover over it,
the green lines highlight
what gets called when that
agent is getting called.
So if you'd like stepped
down the left side
at various times, all of
those little green lines
will be pointing at different boxes.
So each step in that
process is what, you know,
number of services that get
called underneath the hood.
So you can see from this,
ooh, this is a problem.
So, when we talk about a service,
we talk about one of those
little boxes on the screen,
even though most people are like,
"Oh, EC2, it's a service."
So, when you come into region build and,
you know, obviously we
need to run instances
to be able to deliver capacity to people
during region build, right?
So, like, we gotta build,
you know, at a minimum the number of boxes
that are on this screen and
turns out actually a lot more.
So, when we talk about like, oh,
we need to build EC2,
we're talking in the order
of a couple hundred different services.
And those services just like, you know,
EC2 depends on S3 and Dynamo,
those services depend on each other.
So it gets really tricky
with this dependency thing.
And like, the engineer thing you wanna do
when you come in is go like, well, wait,
there exists a dependency
graph in which I could order
every box on that screen
in the perfect order
to know what order I need
to build everything in
to be able to build EC2.
And while that is factually accurate,
the reality is that if you
were able to piece together
that dependency graph, one,
it would take you a
while to do it, and two,
if I was able to, like, wave my magic wand
and have that dependency graph to exist
at this very second in time,
it would be outta date tomorrow.
Because every one of those teams
of eight to 10 software engineers,
they're writing code every day.
And they're changing the behavior
of this system every day.
And actually, the reason why we built
this API orchestration framework
is we need every box on
that to be able to change
how API calls work in order to
deliver new features for you
and not be dependent on, oh,
'cause it used to be, we
had to talk to every person
on that screen to go, oh,
we're gonna have to change run instance,
like everybody needs to
get on the same page.
So, chasing dependencies
in a distributed system
can be a bit of a fool's errand.
So how the heck do we make this thing
actually work in a region build?
Well, we've got this trick up our sleeve,
and the trick is this thing
called static stability.
Static stability.
Usually, when we talk
about static stability,
we talk about it in the
context of, you know,
have you tried unplugging it
and plugging it back in, right?
So, you know, we do that
for entire data centers
or availability zones
if the power goes out
and the generators for
some reason don't come on,
which happens from time to time.
You know, all of the servers
in the data center go off.
And then usually, the power
comes back on at some point.
And once the power comes back on,
all of the servers in the
data center turn back on.
And wouldn't it be nice
if, when that happened,
EC2 just came back to
life, and it didn't require
hundreds of engineers going in and going,
"Oh my gosh, I gotta
get my service working,"
and then you have that dependency problem.
Well, that's static stability, right?
So one, because we run EC2 on EC2,
we want the special EC2
instances that run EC2
to be able to come back
and not lose their state.
And secondary to that, we
want all of the services
to come up and just start working
without hundreds of engineers
having to go in and poke things.
Well, in order to make that work,
you actually have to build
your services in a certain way.
And the way that we build our
services is kinda twofold.
The first is that I don't
take a lotta dependencies
to get my software from, you know,
existing to running.
I may not be able to do much, right?
Like maybe I need, you know,
in order to run a web server,
I probably can't start
if I don't have my SSL certificate, right?
'Cause like that's not
gonna work very well.
I kinda need that.
But do I really need to talk
to the monitoring system
to be able to admit metrics
just to get started?
No.
Do I need to be able to
actually talk to the database?
Do I need to talk to DynamoDB
to start my service up?
Well, not really, right?
I can handle API requests.
I can't do anything with them.
You know, I'll get my
little web server running,
and it'll happily sit there
and return a 500 error
to anything that calls me.
But if I can minimize
the dependency surface
that it takes just to get
my service started and,
you know, for those few
dependencies that I need,
like my SSL cert or, you know,
my IAM creds to be able to call something,
those things are kind of important,
and you need those to start up,
I'll just sit in an infinite loop
and go, can I start?
Crash. Can I start?
Oh, I can start.
I got my IAM creds, my cert,
so I'll start.
Oh, I can't talk to
any of my dependencies,
so everybody who calls
me just gets an error,
but that's data that I didn't have before.
So, static stability starts
in how we build software
in that our services continually
try to activate themselves
no matter what, and they'll
start with a minimum set of,
you know, a minimal dependency
footprint and then respond,
you know, based on, you know,
okay, when you make an API call to me,
if I can't talk to my dependency,
I'll return you an error.
But when my dependency comes online,
the next time you make an API call,
up, you get a 200.
Great, it works.
We can use this in region build
because while I can't build
that perfect dependency map
of what EC2 looks like today,
I can put stuff in buckets, right?
I can put stuff in the, you know,
foundational database bucket of EC2
and the provisioning bucket
and the fancy API layer bucket.
And if I group services into, you know,
groups of like 20 or 30 or 50,
all I need to do is launch all 50
and then kinda let God sort it
out for a little bit, right?
Like let them all sit
and spin for a little bit
and send API traffic through the system.
And in a perfect world,
everything will get to active,
all of the dependency things
will solve each other,
and API calls will start to work.
In the more realistic scenario where,
you know, maybe 75% of everything works,
well, at least I got 75% working,
and then I can kinda go poke
along the API call path,
fix the one or two things
that didn't come up,
and now everything is working.
So we can use this thing
that we do to recover
from major outages and actually
use it to our advantage
to not have to really get into
granular dependency mapping
and project management, and
instead kinda go with the,
like, well, let's just do this in batches
and let this thing figure itself out.
So kind of moving on from that,
we're able to talk about like,
all right, that sounds cool.
How do we actually, like,
make this happen in real life
and do things like testing
to make sure that this
stuff actually works?
- Yeah, so this all sounds
great in theory, right?
And we might plan for
this, engineer for it,
but how do we know it actually works?
Well, we run game days.
So, regardless of the type of build,
regions, AZs, local zones,
we have time in the schedule
dedicated to game day testing.
And that time is used
to actually test things
like what would happen if we power down
an entire availability zone.
And so we'll just pull the plug on the AZ,
and we'll see what happens.
Do things recover gracefully,
or do we have some gaps to close?
And these game days have
proven to be so valuable.
We actually built an entire test region
to do game day testing.
So we did an entire region
build just for this test region.
It has three availability zones,
all of the AWS services are there,
and we run game days
there very frequently.
And what this allowed us to
do is move the game days away
from just being tied to specific builds
because, you know, there are
only so many builds in a year.
So many game days you can do.
In this test environment,
we can run game days
whenever we want to
because those learnings
are extremely valuable.
What better way to learn
than when things go
disastrously wrong?
And sometimes things do go wrong.
So whenever there is an incident,
whether during a game day
or in a production region,
our first priority is
always to mitigate impact.
However, after we've done that,
we wanna make sure that we
figure out what went wrong.
So one of the mechanisms
we have at Amazon,
not just in the build space
but across the company,
is a correction of errors
mechanism or a COE.
So after we've mitigated
the impact of an event,
the service team will actually go in
and do a root cause analysis.
So they'll author this document.
There's a specific format for it.
There are tied deadlines around it,
and you really dive deep
into what caused the issue.
You assign action items to
your own engineering team
and to other engineering
teams to close gaps.
And the the primary thing here
is it's not meant to be punitive.
So the root cause of
an issue can never be,
oh, it was operator error.
They fat-fingered something.
The reason why we don't
let that be a root cause
is because we're not going deep enough.
You know, what enabled
them to be able to do
something like that?
It can't just be a person's fault.
And so the COE process is very effective
in getting learnings from
when things go wrong,
but we actually extend that
to beyond just that individual team.
So at AWS, we have ops meetings.
So these are at various levels.
We have them at the org level,
EC2, and even AWS-wide.
And during these ops meetings,
which are typically led
by our principal engineers,
everyone will review COEs
and dashboards, and
there'll be a discussion on,
you know, one or two COEs.
And in fact, sometimes
the principal engineers
will assign action items to other teams,
because oftentimes when
there's an operational issue
and a team identifies some gaps,
it's not just that team that
could learn from that event.
There are learnings that
could be implemented
in other places as well.
And the ops meeting is one
way that we, as a company,
really prioritize sharing those learnings.
And they happen on a weekly basis.
Attendance is required.
So, it's a huge part of the culture
and a great mechanism to
ensure that we're improving.
And then finally, operational
readiness reviews or ORRs.
So this is a process teams
go through on a regular basis
to ensure that their services
are operationally healthy.
And so this is for existing services,
but also if a service team
is developing a new service
or a new feature, they would
undergo this ORR process,
which also incorporates
some of the learnings from,
you know, noteworthy COEs.
So these are some of the
mechanisms that we use
across the company to, you know,
really drive this culture
of continuous improvement
through those mechanisms and testing.
Let's move on to some more key takeaways.
Hopefully, you can learn a bit
from what we've learned
over the last few years.
- Yeah, so the first is, you know,
I kind of, (coughs) excuse me,
I got sick before re:Invent, so figures.
One is, you know, we kind of alluded to it
like throughout the talk,
but all of our services
that we build, you know,
are kind of architected from the ground up
with how we do resiliency, right?
So our services are aware of, you know,
hey, I am a zonal service,
and I am running in this zone,
and here are the other zonal
services that I talk to.
Like that's really baked
into all of our services,
especially our stateful
services, but even,
you know, services that
handle API call path for EC2,
they are like, you know,
built from the beginning.
You know, those AZs and the bootstrap VPC
are not just there for show.
We need that because our
software depends on knowing what,
you know, oh, I am a zonal service,
and I am running in this zone, therefore,
like I talk to other stuff in that zone,
and that's handled
through things like DNS.
So trying to be able to incorporate that
as you build services on our
infrastructure and decide,
like what failure modes do you want
for what components of your system,
and how do you design your
foundational infrastructure
in your VPC networking and
in your DNS infrastructure
around that to really
have those strong silos
between your components?
Second is, you know,
when to centralize tasks versus
when to distribute tasks.
And we didn't quite get into this a ton,
but Michelle and I worked
on the same team in EC2
for a number of years.
And that team was actually dedicated
to doing region build for EC2.
So for those hundreds of teams
that were on the, you know,
kind of cringe API diagram,
we actually were a team
that if a service team met our bar
for automating their region build,
we would do their region build for them.
Fun fact, if you're on a service team,
nobody likes doing region
builds, like everybody.
So, like, everybody was like, "Oh yeah,
you wanna do my region build for me?
Sure, I'll make sure my
region build is automated
so the central team could do it."
And and that was actually
like a novel thing
that we discovered over time.
So that program is called
manage builds inside of EC2.
We also have another program
called managed fleets.
So each two pizza team, when
I said they were responsible
for everything, that included,
you know, how many hosts do I have
in every zone, in every region?
And, oh, I have to patch my hosts,
and I have to, like, fix broken hosts
and do all these things with hosts.
And for a service team like EC2
where you're running in every
region around the world,
and we keep adding more regions,
that actually is a lot of work.
Again, people don't like doing it.
Nobody likes patching their
infrastructure, right?
Like, let's be honest.
So, we actually started
to develop centralized,
you know, the problem is every
team spends an hour a week
on patching their hosts, if
they're doing a good job.
So when you have thousands of teams,
they're spending thousands of hours
on doing this undifferentiated work.
But no one team is centralized
to actually make that any better.
What happens when you take
that thousand hours of work
and put it on one central team?
Well, all of a sudden,
they're really incentivized
to build really cool systems
to make patching hosts
happen at Amazon scale
really, really fast
and efficient and safe.
And that's what happened
in the region build space.
Amazon, generally speaking,
was this like kind of,
I guess you could call it anarchy, right?
Of all these teams just run around
and kind of do whatever
strikes their fancy.
That's just how we do things.
Over time, we discovered
that while that provides
a lot of value and you can go really fast,
sometimes centralizing
things is actually better.
And it's really important, you know,
each business is gonna be different
because it's different how you do things.
But you really should think about, hey,
when is it time to centralize this work
versus when is it time
to keep it distributed?
Because the flip side of that is,
you know, we struggle as,
you know, a centralized team with,
well, when region builds
become somebody else's problem,
my incentive to maintain my
automation is not that great,
and my incentive to, like,
not do screwy things with my
host is not that great, right?
So there's a natural tension there,
which is why Amazon defaulted to, oh no,
you're a service team, you own everything.
And, oh, by the way,
you're going on call for it.
So if you do something
silly and you get paged
at two in the morning, you will
be incentivized to fix that.
So there's a trade off there, and I think,
you know, exploring that
as part of your business
and as part of your development life cycle
is really important.
Next, do everything in code.
Please, do everything in code.
All of our infrastructure is in code.
You know, obviously, we use
a lot of CDK internally.
Everything is complicated when
you run a low-level service
'cause cloud formation runs on us,
so we can't use cloud formation.
So we have an internal infrastructure
as code framework that we use,
but, like, everything is
in infrastructure as code,
and any type of regionalized config
is actually auto-generated
as part of the build process, right?
And that gets into things
like have predictable DNS
endpoints for your service,
either at the regional or zonal level,
'cause then you could just
have a little Ruby script,
that ones that generates those endpoints
for every single region that
you ever wanna build in,
and then you never need
to think about it again.
And same goes for configuration
in the software that you run.
Like generate that at build
time, don't think about it,
have that live in your source control.
We go, you know,
we go a step further, and actually,
this is becoming a little
bit more interesting
as we're starting to use some
of the generative AI tools
for coding more, is most stuff in Amazon,
most knowledge is in
this gigantic wiki site.
And you can write infrastructure as code
to generate wiki pages.
'Cause we actually use wiki pages like,
for our operational
dashboards for services.
So even our runbooks and
dashboards for services
are captured in our
infrastructure as code.
The reason I mentioned
kinda the gen AI thing
is a lot more teams have been doing it.
You can get it to write
halfway decent documentation.
I can attest to this.
And it can do things
like graphs and diagrams
pretty well in markdown.
So more stuff, more
documentation is actually going
into source control as markdown over time
as some of our projects like
start to use this stuff more.
So I'd encourage you to, like,
really give that a try because, like,
the more stuff we put in source control,
it's easier to search.
It goes through two PR, like
it generally has a structure
of, like, if you show me a repo,
I know generally where to find stuff
depending on what programming
language it's written in.
So, like, really having
everything in your source control
or repository system versus, like,
some document repository
that no one really likes
is generally a best practice.
- And we have continuous improvement.
So, we'll use builds as an example.
Builds are, you know,
a very, very long project.
And so there's a tendency to say, "Oh,
you know, we'll talk about lessons learned
and retrospectives once
the build is done."
The problem is so much time passes,
things have changed, people forget.
So we really encourage, you know,
to continuously look
at what didn't go well
and iterate quickly.
And the way we've done
this, as an example,
a few years ago, there
was this real push at AWS
to have service teams
automate their builds,
and we'd notice trends.
So for example, we'd see that,
you know, a hundred different teams
were running into the same blocker
when trying to automate their builds.
And so instead of, you know, waiting
and letting every single team
work through that issue
themselves, we took a step back,
paused and said, "Okay, well,
this doesn't make sense.
Why would we have every single team
work through the same issue?
How about we cut a tracking SIM?
Make sure it's documented.
And we escalate that and
ensure that the owning team
resolves that centrally, and that way,
you know, the next build,
this isn't an automation
blocker for those hundred teams,
and those a hundred
teams don't have to worry
about implementing
workarounds themselves."
Similarly, we've had sticky
parts of the build where,
you know, there was a lot of churn,
ownership isn't clear, a lot
of back and forth on tickets.
And so instead of just
having that same issue
every single build, because
it's just a tricky part
of the build, what we've done in the past
is we've actually assigned
principal engineers
to that ambiguous problem and
then have them own that space,
find owners and drive
improvements instead of, you know,
just letting it be an
issue over and over again.
And you know, taking that approach
of looking at each
specific phase of the build
and doing a quick
retrospective, lessons learned,
anything so that you can
quickly implement some changes
before the next build has
really helped us improve things
very rapidly.
And the time we see the most improvement
is actually when we have
several builds back to back
with like a short gap in
between because we can implement
lessons learned and then hit the next one
without those issues.
And so we slowly make
progress across each build.
And we've actually, in the past,
staggered builds on purpose
to make sure that we're not just running
into the exact same issue
in four different builds
at the same time, which is very painful
for everyone involved.
And then finally, culture.
So one thing that's incredibly
important in general
but specifically in the
build space is, you know,
we have engineers who are
actually doing the work.
They are building out their services.
They're building their automation.
And so they need to feel empowered
to vocalize when things
are just not working.
You know, if they are running
into those automation blockers
or if they've been going
back and forth on this issue
over and over again, we wanna
make sure that those concerns
are heard and escalated to leadership
so we can actually prioritize fixing them.
And so at Amazon,
we have this very healthy
escalation culture.
So when our engineers or anyone, really,
if they say like, "Hey, this
is a really big problem,"
we make sure that our
leadership hears that.
Leadership does need to
be willing to listen,
and luckily our leadership does.
So we use that escalation culture
to very quickly align on a path forward.
And this is specifically
important for builds because,
you know, once we make a
commitment to our customers
to launch a region at a
specific time of year,
we need to meet that commitment.
And so builds move very, very quickly.
And if there's any friction,
we need to escalate that quickly
and all get on the same
page so we can move forward.
So culture is extremely
important in general,
but especially if you have, you know,
very large projects that span
multiple months or even years.
So these are some of our,
you know, main takeaways.
Hopefully, they've been helpful to you.
If you want to learn
more, we have two topics
that might be interesting
if you enjoyed this session.
And then we have some
builder library resources,
one on static stability,
and then one on building
resilience services.
So those are the two QR codes.
We thank you so much for your time.
Please, please, please take the survey.
- Yes please.
- We need that feedback.
And we hope you have a great
rest of your re:Invent.
Thank you.
- Thanks.